with Millions traveling for the holidays
many won't be back until the new year
Victoria Saha has tips from experts to
prepare your house as you head out the
door and make sure you're not the next
Target for thieves
it's the most wonderful time of the year
but it could also turn frightful if you
aren't too careful as Santa checks his
list once or twice to see if you've been
naughty or nice before you leave for
vacation you should also have your own
list to make sure you aren't on thin ice
talk to your neighbors
um I do that when I go out of town let
them know that you're going to be out of
town Mary rendina with campco a
Homeowners Association Management
company says there are several ways you
can protect your home while you were
gone such as securing all doors and
windows and have sensor lights that can
motion detect and to throw potential
burglars off make sure it seems like
someone's home you can leave a car in
the driveway put some lights on inside
on a timer that helps as well but
according to private investigator Scott
Martin don't leave valuables in the car
either make sure you put your garage
door openers in your house secure them
somewhere so if somebody does get into
your car they don't have access into
housed and if you aren't going on
vacation that new TV you just received
for Christmas doesn't have to be
anyone's business make sure to cut up
all holiday box packaging and put them
inside your trash bin so no one knows
what you got for Christmas Victoria Saha
eight news now it's also a good idea to
stop your mail until you get back from
vacation this time of year there could
be checks gift cards and sometimes cash
that could easily be taken from your
mailbox